En qué consiste la propuesta y realmente
hay una influencia de Rusia como dicen
los opositores en Georgia
Un saludo para ti María efectivamente
hay una influencia rusa muy importante
debido a que hay una copia casi que
exacta de lo que sucedió en digamos en
el trámite legislativo ruso con lo que
está pasando ahora en Georgia es
importante entender que esta ley es una
ley que es muy discriminatoria porque al
final de cuentas lo que hace es que
aquellas organizaciones que reciben más
fondos por parte de organizaciones
internacionales pues ya tienen de alguna
forma un trato diferencial frente a
otras organizaciones No gubernamentales
eso también si se pone en digamos en en
contexto Pues también está un poco
relacionado a la criminalización de la
sociedad civil en cuanto a estas
organizaciones van a tener mucho más
vigilancia por parte del Estado de hecho
lo que se busca es que incluso Más allá
de la de la mera digamos tope de
financiación es que el Ministerio de
Justicia pueda ser investigaciones muy
arbitrarias sobre estas organizaciones
no gubernamentales de lo que sí podemos
ver un poco como una especie de
emulación legislativa por parte de este
proyecto georgiano de lo que de alguna
forma se menciona del texto ruso que
amigos de tema porque las leyes de
agentes extranjeros que se han aplicado
o que se están aplicando en Georgia y se
esperan aplicar allí También se han
hecho en países como Nicaragua Rusia
Hungría Israel Australia y Venezuela por
qué tanta fuerza para restringir a las
ongs
Bueno hay algo muy importante y es que
este fenómeno no solamente es un
fenómeno que se da en el espacio
possoviético sino que también se da un
poco en lo que uno podría llamar la
cooperación autoritaria Es que muchos
líderes autoritarios autócratas
aspirantes a dictadores pues han visto
que a pesar de que puedan tener
diferencias ideológicas pues pueden
compartir de alguna forma un gran
problema y es como consolidar o como
concentrar mayor poder y una de las
formas que se puede concentrar poderes
manteniendo a la sociedad civil
totalmente acallada de alguna forma sea
algo muy importante que se puede notar
digamos en este tipo de fenómenos es que
si bien los autócratas han podido
controlar las instituciones del estado
siempre queda una oposición remanente
que es la sociedad civil por lo tanto
muchas veces estos líderes terminan más
allá digamos de controlar las
instituciones del estado y pasando una
etapa en donde hay un control social muy
fuerte y esto es una expresión muy
importante por lo que se con las ong